This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.|||这是一个 I-Heart 播客。绝对真人。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持体能以及构筑适应力。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.|||经历一些艰难困苦，你将迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上搜索 TWO percent。在《Look Back at it》播客中。1979年，那对我是个大时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.|||我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当年发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。确实是个疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.|||在 IHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加姆斯带来的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都无法坦诚倾诉的真诚对话，而你是在与一位经验丰富的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你非得这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.|||在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德被指控使人怀上双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的规律。还有两名男性也经历过同样的事情。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody.
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody.|||迈克尔·曼奇尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好。
Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here. Back for another episode. as we of course break down some of the psychology of our 20s. I'm going to come right out and say it. The biggest questions that we have in our 20s and the questions that I get the most of
Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here. Back for another episode. as we of course break down some of the psychology of our 20s. I'm going to come right out and say it. The biggest questions that we have in our 20s and the questions that I get the most of|||欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身处世界何地。很高兴你能来到这里。欢迎收听又一期节目。当然，我们要剖析一些关于20多岁时的心理学。我就直说吧。我们在20多岁时遇到的最大问题，以及我收到最多的问题是
revolve around dating. Like how exactly are we meant to do this? How do I stop getting attached so quickly? How do I know if this person likes me? If I even like them, how do I find the one and not be completely exhausted by the process or the biggest question of all? Is this something that I should even be prioritizing during my 20s? You know, alternatively, could this be my decade to just be like free and uninhibited and not worry about this process?
revolve around dating. Like how exactly are we meant to do this? How do I stop getting attached so quickly? How do I know if this person likes me? If I even like them, how do I find the one and not be completely exhausted by the process or the biggest question of all? Is this something that I should even be prioritizing during my 20s? You know, alternatively, could this be my decade to just be like free and uninhibited and not worry about this process?|||都围绕着约会。比如我们到底该怎么做？我该如何停止那么快对别人产生依赖？我怎么知道这个人是否喜欢我？如果我都不知道自己是否喜欢他们，我又该如何找到对的人，而又不会在这个过程中精疲力竭呢？或者最大的问题是：在我20多岁的时候，这真的是我应该优先考虑的事情吗？你知道，换句话说，这会不会是我可以随性不羁、不必为这个过程操心的十年？
I think that I am there with you and so many of us are. It is occasionally, you know, dating is more trouble than it's worth. But I also deeply believe that dating shouldn't be a chore. It should be something that's fun and exciting and that you don't feel any pressure towards. and that there is some pretty amazing ways to go about it that bring us to this point. The question that that leaves us with, and I know I'm full of a lot of questions, is how do we get there? How do we get to that point? And to give us the expert advice on how to date, when to date, and who to date in your 20s,
I think that I am there with you and so many of us are. It is occasionally, you know, dating is more trouble than it's worth. But I also deeply believe that dating shouldn't be a chore. It should be something that's fun and exciting and that you don't feel any pressure towards. and that there is some pretty amazing ways to go about it that bring us to this point. The question that that leaves us with, and I know I'm full of a lot of questions, is how do we get there? How do we get to that point? And to give us the expert advice on how to date, when to date, and who to date in your 20s,|||我想我和你们一样，我们中的很多人都有同感。有时候，你知道的，约会带来的麻烦大于它的价值。但我同时也坚信，约会不应该是一件苦差事。它应该是一件有趣、刺激且让你感受不到任何压力的事情。而且有一些非常棒的方法可以带我们走到这一步。由此留给我们的问题——我知道我满脑子都是问题——是我们该如何到达那里？我们如何才能到达那种状态？为了给我们提供关于20多岁时如何约会、何时约会以及与谁约会的专家建议，
we have the host of the outstanding podcast, Datable. Julie and you, a welcome to the show. Thanks for having us, Jan. I love your voice. I'm just so sued by your voice right now. Thanks so much, guys. You know, a little bit of ASMR to kick soon out. Just that morning. Can you introduce yourself and introduce Datable?
we have the host of the outstanding podcast, Datable. Julie and you, a welcome to the show. Thanks for having us, Jan. I love your voice. I'm just so sued by your voice right now. Thanks so much, guys. You know, a little bit of ASMR to kick soon out. Just that morning. Can you introduce yourself and introduce Datable?|||我们请来了优秀播客《Datable》的主持人。朱莉和尤娅，欢迎来到节目。谢谢邀请，简。我太喜欢你的声音了。我现在简直被你的声音治愈了。非常感谢各位。你知道的，来点 ASMR 作为节目的开场。就在今天早上。你们能自我介绍一下，并介绍一下《Datable》吗？
Who are you guys? What is the show? Oh, yes. We're going to get right into it. We've had this podcast for almost a decade. We were introduced, Julie and I were introduced by a mutual friend over a decade ago, actually. And we were just sharing what you could. call them war stories of dating. Like, what have you survived? And we thought it was such a great
Who are you guys? What is the show? Oh, yes. We're going to get right into it. We've had this podcast for almost a decade. We were introduced, Julie and I were introduced by a mutual friend over a decade ago, actually. And we were just sharing what you could. call them war stories of dating. Like, what have you survived? And we thought it was such a great|||你们是谁？这个节目是什么？哦，好的。我们直接切入正题。我们做这个播客快十年了。其实十多年前，我和朱莉是通过一个共同的朋友认识的。当时我们只是在分享那些可以被称为约会“战斗故事”的经历。比如，你都经历过什么？我们觉得这真是一个
way to share what's going on in modern dating, share our own experiences, and not feel like we're alone in it. So we decided to do a podcast out of it. But since then, we've really evolved the way we see modern dating. We think we are at a point where people are very fed up with dating. Dating is harder than ever. But also, it gives us the best opportunity to, to date right now. And we can go into that more later and we go into it in our book. But the two of us come from kind of like this, we straddle the old and the new. So, you know, I'm like, I'm like the first millennial. So I'm, you know, I was born in 81. So I'm the first millennial. And I just remember growing up with all these rules about dating, very traditional ways of looking at gender roles.
way to share what's going on in modern dating, share our own experiences, and not feel like we're alone in it. So we decided to do a podcast out of it. But since then, we've really evolved the way we see modern dating. We think we are at a point where people are very fed up with dating. Dating is harder than ever. But also, it gives us the best opportunity to, to date right now. And we can go into that more later and we go into it in our book. But the two of us come from kind of like this, we straddle the old and the new. So, you know, I'm like, I'm like the first millennial. So I'm, you know, I was born in 81. So I'm the first millennial. And I just remember growing up with all these rules about dating, very traditional ways of looking at gender roles.|||很好的方式去分享现代约会中正在发生的事情，分享我们自己的经历，并让我们觉得在这条路上并不孤单。于是我们决定以此做一个播客。但从那以后，我们对现代约会的看法确实发生了演变。我们认为，目前人们对约会已经感到十分厌烦。约会比以往任何时候都更加困难。但同时，这也为我们提供了当下约会的最佳机遇。我们稍后可以深入探讨这一点，我们的书中也有详细论述。不过我们两人都有点……我们跨越了新旧两个时代。所以，你知道的，我有点像第一批千禧一代。所以，你知道的，我出生于81年。所以我属于第一批千禧一代。我只记得在成长过程中，伴随着各种关于约会的规矩，以及非常传统的性别角色观点。
And now with modern dating, we're straddling kind of a progressive view of dating. So I was feeling lost because I only knew kind of the traditional ways of dating, like, who pays for what and who should text and who should initiate. And here I was in a world where all the rules are kind of thrown out the window. And I had to recreate a love life that worked for me. And I didn't know where to start. So that's where I was when I met Julie. Yeah. And where I was, I don't think I ever set up.
And now with modern dating, we're straddling kind of a progressive view of dating. So I was feeling lost because I only knew kind of the traditional ways of dating, like, who pays for what and who should text and who should initiate. And here I was in a world where all the rules are kind of thrown out the window. And I had to recreate a love life that worked for me. And I didn't know where to start. So that's where I was when I met Julie. Yeah. And where I was, I don't think I ever set up.|||而现在面对现代约会，我们则夹在一种进步的约会观念中间。所以我当时感到很迷茫，因为我只知道传统的约会方式，比如谁来付账、谁该发短信、谁该主动。而我却身处一个所有规矩都被抛到九霄云外的世界里。我不得不重新创造一个适合我自己的爱情生活。我不知道该从哪里开始。这就是我遇到朱莉时的状态。是的。而当时的我是这样的，我想我从来没有
out to be a dating expert. So it still makes me laugh every day. But I was just as confused as probably many people that are listening are right this minute of just where to date. I got all the old books. We were kind of talking about that before we got on here, you know, why men love bitches and, you know, the rules. And I thought I would approach dating like I did like schoolwork or a job and really study up and learn all the ways to navigate it. And I think that's why those books were so appealing because they gave you a framework. The problem was I was not myself at all in the process. And I just remember friends being like, you're so social, you've so many friends. Like, why does dating not stick ever? And I was just lost. And, you know, I think when I met UA, I was actually coming out of like my first real serious relationship. And at that point, I was like, you know, I found someone. I did it. I made it work. And then it didn't. And it wasn't. And it wasn't because. And it wasn't because. And it wasn't because. And it was. And it was. And it was. And it was like, you know, it was like, you know, I was because the love wasn't there, I realized just like not all the time things happen the way like we're told they are and like in the movies and, you know, this simplistic view of relationships.
out to be a dating expert. So it still makes me laugh every day. But I was just as confused as probably many people that are listening are right this minute of just where to date. I got all the old books. We were kind of talking about that before we got on here, you know, why men love bitches and, you0and the rules. And I thought I would approach dating like I did like schoolwork or a job and really study up and learn all the ways to navigate it. And I think that's why those books were so appealing because they gave you a framework. The problem was I was not myself at all in the process. And I just remember friends being like, you're so social, you've so many friends. Like, why does dating not stick ever? And I was just lost. And, you know, I think when I met UA, I was actually coming out of like my first real serious relationship. And at that point, I was like, you know, I found someone. I did it. I made it work. And then it didn't. And it wasn't. And it wasn't because. And it wasn't because. And it was. And it was. And it was. And it was like, you know, it was like, you know, I was because the love wasn't there, I realized just like not all the time things happen the way like we're told they are and like in the movies and, you know, this simplistic view of relationships.|||立志成为一名约会专家。所以这至今每天都让我觉得好笑。但我当时和此时此刻正在收听节目的许多人一样困惑，不知道该在哪里约会。我读过所有老式的情感书。我们在上节目之前还聊过这个，你知道的，比如《为什么男人爱坏女人》以及诸如此类的规则。我曾以为自己可以像对待功课或工作那样来对待约会，认真研究并学习所有应对它的方法。我想这也是那些书如此吸引人的原因，因为它们为你提供了一个框架。问题在于，在这个过程中我完全迷失了自己。我只记得朋友们曾对我说：“你这么社牛，有那么多朋友。为什么约会总是谈不长久呢？”我当时完全不知所措。而且，你知道，当我遇到尤娅时，我其实刚结束我的第一段真正严肃的感情。当时我想，你知道的，我找到人恋爱了。我做到了，我让它成功了。但后来它还是结束了。而且不是因为……而且不是因为……而且不是因为……而且是因为……因为爱已经不在了，我意识到，并非所有事情都会像别人告诉我们的那样发生，也不像电影里演的那样，更不是那种对关系的简单化看法。
And I think it just made us both really curious on the topic and want to dive in even more. I love that this was like an accidental career for you both. Oh, 100%. You're gravitated to things, right, that you like struggle with. Oh, 100%. you know, the psychology of your 20s. I have no idea what I'm doing. That's the whole reason I'm doing this book. But you do. But you do know what you're doing. Maybe I do. Yeah, exactly. And then you learn all the got long the way, right? I know. I just get to interview really smart
And I think it just made us both really curious on the topic and want to dive in even more. I love that this was like an accidental career for you both. Oh, 100%. You're gravitated to things, right, that you like struggle with. Oh, 100%. you know, the psychology of your 20s. I have no idea what I'm doing. That's the whole reason I'm doing this book. But you do. But you do know what you're doing. Maybe I do. Yeah, exactly. And then you learn all the got long the way, right? I know. I just get to interview really smart|||我想这让我们俩对这个话题都产生了极大的好奇，并想要进行更深入的探讨。我喜欢这对于你们俩来说是一个无心插柳的职业。哦，百分之百。你总是会被那些你曾经挣扎过的事物所吸引，对吧？哦，百分之百。你知道的，关于20多岁时的心理学。我完全不知道自己在做什么。这就是我写这本书的全部原因。但你知道。但你确实知道自己在做什么。也许我知道吧。对，确实如此。然后你在这一路上学到了所有东西，对吧？我懂的。我只是有机会去采访那些非常聪明的
experts and they just give me all the tips like yourselves. But I do think that you raised a really interesting point, which is that dating in this day and age is very different. And I think that a lot of us are bringing very outdated ideas of what that looks. And I think that looks like. Outdated ideas of like what are the games that we have to play? What are the rules to follow? Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. Why do you think that those rules are actually, you know, I don't want to say worsening our chances, but making it so much harder for us to actually enjoy the process? Well, if you think about it, dating is for you. You're not dating for other people. yet we are restrained by these rules that other people have created for us, these social constructs, that are not serving us for most part and not helping us in any way.
experts and they just give me all the tips like yourselves. But I do think that you raised a really interesting point, which is that dating in this day and age is very different. And I think that a lot of us are bringing very outdated ideas of what that looks. And I think that looks like. Outdated ideas of like what are the games that we have to play? What are the rules to follow? Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. Why do you think that those rules are actually, you6don't want to say worsening our chances, but making it so much harder for us to actually enjoy the process? Well, if you think about it, dating is for you. You're not dating for other people. yet we are restrained by these rules that other people have created for us, these social constructs, that are not serving us for most part and not helping us in any way.|||专家，他们会把所有的秘诀都告诉我，就像你们一样。不过我确实觉得你们提出了一个非常有趣的观点，那就是现如今的约会已经大不相同了。而且我认为我们中的许多人都带着非常过时的观念去看待约会。我认为这看起来像。那些过时的观念，比如我们必须玩什么游戏？要遵循什么规则？等等等等。为什么你认为这些规则其实——我不想说是恶化了我们的机会，而是让享受这个过程变得如此困难？嗯，如果你仔细想想，约会是为了你自己。你不是为了别人而约会。然而，我们却被其他人为我们创造的这些规则、这些社会结构所束缚，而这些对我们大部分人来说毫无用处，也帮不上任何忙。
So just by virtue of saying there are these rules already puts us in a box and doesn't free us from being our most authentic selves in dating. Yeah. I think this is kind of a weird response as to dating experts, but what of the things? we've realized in our decade is you actually don't need to be good at dating. Maybe it's actually hurting you because the way dating is operates today. We're not saying to not date. It's maybe to change how we date. But the way it operates today, it's all centered around disconnection, when all we really crave is connection. And the games, like we hear, you know, people are like, well, I'm over the games. I don't do that. But that we hear them say like, oh, but, you know, I'm going to wait half an hour to text that person back because they didn't text me back right away.
So just by virtue of saying there are these rules already puts us in a box and doesn't free us from being our most authentic selves in dating. Yeah. I think this is kind of a weird response as to dating experts, but what of the things? we've realized in our decade is you actually don't need to be good at dating. Maybe it's actually hurting you because the way dating is operates today. We're not saying to not date. It's maybe to change how we date. But the way it operates today, it's all centered around disconnection, when all we really crave is connection. And the games, like we hear, you know, people are like, well, I'm over the games. I don't do that. But that we hear them say like, oh, but, you know, I'm going to wait half an hour to text that person back because they didn't text me back right away.|||所以，仅仅因为说存在这些规则，就已经把我们关进了一个盒子里，无法让我们在约会中做最真实的自己。是的。作为约会专家，这可能是一个奇怪的回答，但在过去十年中我们意识到的事情之一是，你其实根本不需要擅长约会。也许这反而在伤害你，因为以当今约会的运作方式来看。我们并不是说不要去约会。或许是要改变我们约会的方式。但就它如今的运作方式而言，它完全围绕着“断联”，而我们真正渴望的却是连接。还有那些游戏，就像我们听到的那样，你知道，有人会说：“哦，我对这些游戏已经厌倦了。我不玩那一套。”但我们又会听到他们说：“哦，不过呢，我要等半小时再给那个人回信息，因为他们没有立刻回我信息。”
That's a game. And it's like all so baked into dating culture that we don't always even realize when we're playing games. I really like that point. It's like is the biggest mistake that we're making not being authentic? Like is it just seriously back to basics? Oh my God. There we go. Done.
That's a game. And it's like all so baked into dating culture that we don't always even realize when we're playing games. I really like that point. It's like is the biggest mistake that we're making not being authentic? Like is it just seriously back to basics? Oh my God. There we go. Done.|||这就是游戏。这已经深深融入了约会文化中，以至于我们在玩游戏时甚至不总是能意识到这一点。我非常喜欢这个观点。这是否意味着我们犯下的最大错误就是不够真实？这难道真的是回归本源吗？天哪。就是这样。搞定。
Episode over. And that was. It's actually going to be one of my questions. I was going to be that you guys are the dating experts. What's the biggest mistake that we're making? What's the thing we're getting wrong about dating? Is it that we're not authentic? And is it that we're trying to be someone that we're not in the first week, month, day, year of dating someone? I mean, you did a recent episode about dating burnout. And we truly believe that you feel burnt out when you are not true to yourself. Because you're exerting more energy to be something you're not. That's a lot. That's a lot. how you get burnt out. But if you're authentic to who you are and your needs, then you feel energized. Like dating should feel energizing if you're doing it in a way that serves you, right? So I think you're onto something there, Gemma. Maybe the biggest issue is we're all trying to be something we're not. And that's what's causing us to be burnt out, to feel overwhelmed, to feel completely
Episode over. And that was. It's actually going to be one of my questions. I was going to be that you guys are the dating experts. What's the biggest mistake that we're making? What's the thing we're getting wrong about dating? Is it that we're not authentic? And is it that we're trying to be someone that we're not in the first week, month, day, year of dating someone? I mean, you did a recent episode about dating burnout. And we truly believe that you feel burnt out when you are not true to yourself. Because you're exerting more energy to be something you're not. That's a lot. That's a lot. how you get burnt out. But if you're authentic to who you are and your needs, then you feel energized. Like dating should feel energizing if you're doing it in a way that serves you, right? So I think you're onto something there, Gemma. Maybe the biggest issue is we're all trying to be something we're not. And that's what's causing us to be burnt out, to feel overwhelmed, to feel completely|||本集结束。刚才那是……这本来也是我的问题之一。我本想问，既然你们是约会专家，我们犯的最大错误是什么？我们在约会上弄错的是什么？是不是我们不够真实？是不是我们在与某人约会的第一周、第一个月、第一天或第一年里，试图成为一个并非真实的自己？我的意思是，你们最近做了一期关于约会倦怠的节目。我们深信，当你对你不真实时，你就会感到倦怠。因为你在消耗更多能量去扮演一个你不是的人。这消耗太大了。这就是你如何感到倦怠的。但如果你忠于自我和自己的需求，你就会感到充满活力。如果你的约会方式对你有利，那么约会应该让你充满活力，对吧？所以我觉得你抓住了重点，简娜。也许最大的问题是，我们都在试图成为并非真实的自己。而这正是导致我们精疲力竭、感到不知所措、感到彻底
failed by modern dating when we just need to take the control back and say, I, am in the driver's seat of my love life and I will make every choice, every action, every behavior is in line with what I authentically stand for, not what society or other people want for me. I also feel like with what you were saying then, when you put on this like false persona, right, you end up attracting people that you don't even lie. And like you said, like it's so draining and you're so burnt out. It's kind of like a friendship. You know, when you just know, that you and a person, you really actually don't get along that well. Like, there really isn't much like chemistry, completely platonically, of course. And you don't remain friends with those people.
failed by modern dating when we just need to take the control back and say, I, am in the driver's seat of my love life and I will make every choice, every action, every behavior is in line with what I authentically stand for, not what society or other people want for me. I also feel like with what you were saying then, when you put on this like false persona, right, you end up attracting people that you don't even lie. And like you said, like it's so draining and you're so burnt out. It's kind of like a friendship. You know, when you just know, that you and a person, you really actually don't get along that well. Like, there really isn't much like chemistry, completely platonically, of course. And you don't remain friends with those people.|||被现代约会辜负的原因，而我们此时只需夺回控制权，并宣称：我，才是自己爱情生活的驾驶员，我将做出每一个选择、采取每一个行动、每一个行为都与我真实代表的立场保持一致，而不是去迎合社会或其他人的期望。我也觉得正如你刚才所说，当你戴上这种虚假的面具时，你最终吸引到的甚至不是你喜欢的人。正如你所说，这太消耗精力了，你会精疲力竭。这有点像友谊。你知道的，当你心里清楚你和一个人的关系其实并没有那么融洽时。比如，纯粹从柏拉图式的角度来看，你们之间并没有什么化学反应。而且你不会和那些人保持朋友关系。
Like, you don't message them, you don't text them, you don't really want to hang out with them. But with dating, it's like the stakes are so high that you give these people second, third, fourth chances. And then you're both exhausted during the relationship. And then afterwards, you probably feel a sense of like, but I did all these things, I did everything right, and it didn't work out. Like, that's the whole, like, that's the whole cycle that I think really frustrates people. Absolutely. And we call it in our book, actually, the validation trap. This is something that's getting in people's way because dating is no longer a way to just meet new people and have fun and see who the right matches. It's basically measuring our self-worth. And that comes from all the pressure
Like, you don't message them, you don't text them, you don't really want to hang out with them. But with dating, it's like the stakes are so high that you give these people second, third, fourth chances. And then you're both exhausted during the relationship. And then afterwards, you probably feel a sense of like, but I did all these things, I did everything right, and it didn't work out. Like, that's the whole, like, that's the whole cycle that I think really frustrates people. Absolutely. And we call it in our book, actually, the validation trap. This is something that's getting in people's way because dating is no longer a way to just meet new people and have fun and see who the right matches. It's basically measuring our self-worth. And that comes from all the pressure|||比如，你不会发信息给他们，不会给他们发短信，也不怎么想和他们一起出去玩。但在约会中，赌注往往太高了，以至于你会给这些人第二次、第三次、第四次机会。然后你们在恋爱期间都精疲力竭。接着在这之后，你可能会有一种感觉：“可是我做了所有这些事，我每件事都做对了，为什么还是没有结果。”这就是整个循环，我认为这正是真正让人沮丧的地方。完全正确。我们在书中把这称为“认可陷阱”。这是阻碍人们前进的绊脚石，因为约会不再仅仅是结识新朋友、获得乐趣以及看看谁是合适伴侣的方式。它基本上成了衡量我们自我价值的标准。而这源于所有的压力
with dating. And, you know, UA and I really fundamentally believe we've talked to like thousands of daters. We've seen people that, you know, felt really hopeless. It's like felt like I've never had a real relationship or I just don't know how to date are now in super healthy relationships. So we really believe that like everyone is datable. That is a core message that we have, but it's modern dating norms that are getting in the way. So you asked earlier, like, what are some of the biggest mistakes? I think it's coming to modern dating culture. Like we had one of our friends come on the podcast and she was saying, how like in every other part of life, she's a go-getter. She, you know, makes plans proactively. If
with dating. And, you know, UA and I really fundamentally believe we've talked to like thousands of daters. We've seen people that, you know, felt really hopeless. It's like felt like I've never had a real relationship or I just don't know how to date are now in super healthy relationships. So we really believe that like everyone is datable. That is a core message that we have, but it's modern dating norms that are getting in the way. So you asked earlier, like, what are some of the biggest mistakes? I think it's coming to modern dating culture. Like we had one of our friends come on the podcast and she was saying, how like in every other part of life, she's a go-getter. She, you know, makes plans proactively. If|||伴随着约会的压力。而且，你知道，尤娅和我从根本上坚信——我们和成千上万个约会者交谈过。我们见过那些曾经感到非常绝望的人，他们觉得自己“从未有过真正的恋爱”或者“根本不知道怎么约会”，而现在他们都拥有了非常健康的亲密关系。所以我们坚信，每个人都是可以去约会的。这是我们想传达的核心信息，但阻碍这一切的是现代约会的规范。所以你刚才问，最大的错误有哪些？我认为是受了现代约会文化的影响。比如我们曾邀请过一位朋友来上播客，她谈到在生活的其他所有方面，她都是个积极进取的人。她总是积极地做计划。如果
someone asks to meet up in a business context, she's on it, a friend asked to meet up, she does it. But in dating, she feels like because like everyone else is putting in less and less effort, it makes her do the same. So then she ghosts because they ghost. And it's a cycle. She drops to what she called the lowest common denominator. And art and her thing was, well, if someone's going to give me 10%, I'll give them 9%. And our take was, why not give them 0%. Like, they're showing you what they're giving. You know what you want to give.
someone asks to meet up in a business context, she's on it, a friend asked to meet up, she does it. But in dating, she feels like because like everyone else is putting in less and less effort, it makes her do the same. So then she ghosts because they ghost. And it's a cycle. She drops to what she called the lowest common denominator. And art and her thing was, well, if someone's going to give me 10%, I'll give them 9%. And our take was, why not give them 0%. Like, they're showing you what they're giving. You know what you want to give.|||有人在商务场合约见面，她二话不说就会去；朋友约见面，她也会赴约。但在约会中，她觉得因为其他人投入的精力越来越少，这导致她也跟着这么做。于是别人玩失踪（ghosting），她也玩失踪。这成了一个恶性循环。她降到了她所谓的“最低公约数”。她的做法是，好吧，如果有人给我10%的付出，我就给他们9%。而我们的看法是，为什么不给他们0%呢？因为他们已经向你展示了他们的付出。而你知道你想付出什么。
Like, how do you rise above dating culture, not just do the thing because that's how dating works. And this validation, was it a validation cycle or validation? Trap. Trap, even better. Could be a cycle as well. Yeah. Yes. Neither. You don't want to be in either of them. Let's just avoid.
Like, how do you rise above dating culture, not just do the thing because that's how dating works. And this validation, was it a validation cycle or validation? Trap. Trap, even better. Could be a cycle as well. Yeah. Yes. Neither. You don't want to be in either of them. Let's just avoid.|||如何才能超越这种约会文化，而不是仅仅因为“约会就是这样运作的”而随波逐流？这个认可，是叫认可循环还是认可？陷阱。陷阱，更好。也可以是循环。是的。都不是。你这两个都不想沾边。我们还是避开吧。
With the validation trap, like, how does it keep us in those like same unsustaining relationships or situationships or dating the wrong people? Yeah, because you are constantly tying yourself worth to other people's behaviors and your perceived perception of how they see you. That even me just saying that sentence is so exhausting, right? Because you're constantly like who you are, what you're worth is a product of how someone else treats you. That's not how life should be. You know your worth and you know what you're putting out there. You know what you bring to the table. Why have other people dictate that? So the danger with a validation trap is you never fully stand strong in who you are. You're not really.
With the validation trap, like, how does it keep us in those like same unsustaining relationships or situationships or dating the wrong people? Yeah, because you are constantly tying yourself worth to other people's behaviors and your perceived perception of how they see you. That even me just saying that sentence is so exhausting, right? Because you're constantly like who you are, what you worth is a product of how someone else treats you. That's not how life should be. You know your worth and you know what you're putting out there. You know what you bring to the table. Why have other people dictate that? So the danger with a validation trap is you never fully stand strong in who you are. You're not really.|||关于认可陷阱，它如何让我们深陷于那些不可持续的恋爱关系、暧昧不清的关系（situationships）或与错误的人约会之中？是的，因为你不断地将自己的自我价值与别人的行为以及你所认为的别人对你的看法捆绑在一起。光是听我说完这句话都觉得让人精疲力竭，对吧？因为你总是觉得你是谁、你的价值是多少，都是别人如何对待你的产物。生活本不该如此。你知道自己的价值，也知道你付出了什么。你知道你能带来什么。为什么要让别人来决定这一切呢？所以，认可陷阱的危险在于，你永远无法真正坚定地做自己。你并没有真正的根基。
rooted. Your branches are just tied to all these other people who are moving in which direction. Like, imagine how weak that tree is if they have no roots but branches tied to all the other trees. You would end up just being, like we call this a dating chameleon, where you just, you know, pretend your other people to try to fit into other people's lives. I think one of the biggest challenges I had personally was situation chips. It was like even before the term existed. I was the queen of situationships, always in them, all through my 20s and even into my early 30s. And finally, I was able to crack that luckily. But I think the biggest piece was with validation is that one, I think I just didn't know like what love actually should look like and what a healthy relationship was. But also, it was this cycle of wanting the approval of someone and feeling like I could win them over. And, you know, I'd already invested so much energy, the sunk cost fallacy. I'm just going to keep going. And it was so tied to my ego that, like, I wanted to win. But I was like winning by settling for someone that
rooted. Your branches are just tied to all these other people who are moving in which direction. Like, imagine how weak that tree is if they have no roots but branches tied to all the other trees. You would end up just being, like we call this a dating chameleon, where you just, you know, pretend your other people to try to fit into other people's lives. I think one of the biggest challenges I had personally was situation chips. It was like even before the term existed. I was the queen of situationships, always in them, all through my 20s and even into my early 30s. And finally, I was able to crack that luckily. But I think the biggest piece was with validation is that one, I think I just didn't know like what love actually should look like and what a healthy relationship was. But also, it was this cycle of wanting the approval of someone and feeling like I could win them over. And, you0and I'd already invested so much energy, the sunk cost fallacy. I'm just going to keep going. And it was so tied to my ego that, like, I wanted to win. But I was like winning by settling for someone that|||你的枝桠只是和所有其他那些朝各个方向移动的人绑在一起。想象一下，如果一棵树没有根，而它的枝桠却和所有其他的树绑在一起，那该有多脆弱。你最终会变成——我们称之为“约会变色龙”，你只是假装成别人来试图融入别人的生活。我认为我个人面临的最大挑战之一就是暧昧关系（situationships）。那甚至在这个词出现之前就有了。我是暧昧关系女王，一直身处其中，整个20多岁甚至一直到30岁出头都是如此。好在我最终成功打破了这一局面。但我认为关于认可，最重要的一点是，首先，我觉得我当时根本不知道真正的爱情应该是什么样子，健康的亲密关系又是什么样。但同时，这也是一个渴望得到某人认可并觉得自己能赢得对方的循环。而且我已经投入了那么多精力，陷入了沉没成本谬误。我只能硬着头皮继续下去。这与我的自我意识（ego）紧密相连，以至于我只想赢。但我所谓的赢，却是委曲求全去和一个
didn't even really want to be with me. Like, that's not winning at all. And I think rejection also ties to that when we're so tied to validation. We want to avoid. rejection at all cost. And then like the most recent time I was dating before I met my partner now three years plus I just lost all of that. Like I got to the point where I was just like, I'm going to show up as myself. If someone doesn't want to be with me, then like I'm going to move on and they're clearing my path to find the right person. But it took a lot of reframing to get to that point and not fall for validation trap anymore. And I'm sure like even with all the knowledge you had, it's still very instinctual. Oh, yeah. It's just, you know, it's basic human
didn't even really want to be with me. Like, that's not winning at all. And I think rejection also ties to that when we're so tied to validation. We want to avoid. rejection at all cost. And then like the most recent time I was dating before I met my partner now three years plus I just lost all of that. Like I got to the point where I was just like, I'm going to show up as myself. If someone doesn't want to be with me, then like I'm going to move on and they're clearing my path to find the right person. But it took a lot of reframing to get to that point and not fall for validation trap anymore. And I'm sure like even with all the knowledge you had, it's still very instinctual. Oh, yeah. It's just, you know, it's basic human|||甚至并不真的想和我在一起的人在一起。这根本算不上赢。而且我认为，当我们过分执着于认可时，拒绝也与之息息相关。我们希望不惜一切代价避免被拒绝。然后，就像在我遇到现任伴侣（在一起三年多了）之前的最近一次约会中，我抛弃了所有这些。我达到了这样一种状态：我只想做最真实的自己。如果有人不想和我在一起，那我就继续前行，他们是在为我寻找对的人清理道路。但要达到这种状态、不再掉入认可陷阱，需要进行大量的认知重构。我敢肯定，即使你拥有所有的知识，这依然是非常本能的反应。哦，是的。这只是，你知道的，这是人类基本的
psychology. Like, you want what you can't have. Like, you end up being led by attraction. Yeah, exactly. It's FOMO. Everyone else has these relationships and you're like, if I can just make this work, like, I can tick that off my list as well. It's so interesting because literally this morning, I've been with my partner for like two years now. You have the best relationship. And this morning, my ex-situation ship messaged me out of the blue. Right before I came on. They always come back. Oh, well. And I was like, uh-huh. Hi. And he sent me like this meme about how, you know, as we're recording this, like, the US election is going on. And he sent me this meme about like how Camel Harris is like banning all situationships. And like anyone who's in a situation ship like, like, who creates a
psychology. Like, you want what you can't have. Like, you end up being led by attraction. Yeah, exactly. It's FOMO. Everyone else has these relationships and you're like, if I can just make this work, like, I can tick that off my list as well. It's so interesting because literally this morning, I've been with my partner for like two years now. You have the best relationship. And this morning, my ex-situation ship messaged me out of the blue. Right before I coming on. They always come back. Oh, well. And I was like, uh-huh. Hi. And he sent me like this meme about how, you know, as we're recording this, like, the US election is going on. And he sent me this meme about like how Camel Harris is like banning all situationships. And like anyone who's in a situation ship like, like, who creates a|||心理学。比如，你总是想要你得不到的东西。比如，你最终会被吸引力所驱使。是的，完全如此。这就是 FOMO（惧怕错过）。别人都有这样的恋爱关系，你就会想：“如果我也能让这段关系成功，那我也可以在我的清单上把它勾掉了。”这太有趣了，因为就在今天早上——我和我的伴侣在一起大概两年了。你们的感情最好了。就在今天早上，我以前的那段暧昧对象突然给我发了信息。就在我上节目之前。他们总是会回头。好吧。当时我的反应是：“呃，嗨。”他发给我一个表情包，内容是——你知道的，在我们录制这个节目的同时，美国大选正在进行。他发给我的表情包大概是关于卡马拉·哈里斯要禁止所有暧昧关系，任何身处暧昧关系中的人——比如，谁创造了
situation ship, like, should go straight to jail. And it was so, I was like, where the fuck is this coming from, mate? Like, I haven't spoken to you in like three years. I'm still thinking about me. Like, I'm with this amazing person now. You know that I'm with this person. But he messaged me and it, I got this feeling in my stomach. It like did a flip. And I was just like, oh my God. And I just felt all of these emotions all over again. And I remember like, you know, three months ago, I was like, why was I, you know, for a while, I'd been like, why was I ever in that situation? And I was like, because he knew how to make me really anxious. And he knew how to like, I think I say there's a lot. It comes down to like being a bit of an
situation ship, like, should go straight to jail. And it was so, I was like, where the fuck is this coming from, mate? Like, I haven't spoken to you in like three years. I'm still thinking about me. Like, I'm with this amazing person now. You know that I'm with this person. But he messaged me and it, I got this feeling in my stomach. It like did a flip. And I was just like, oh my God. And I just felt all of these emotions all over again. And I remember like, you know, three months ago, I was like, why was I, you know, for a while, I'd been like, why was I ever in that situation? And I was like, because he knew how to make me really anxious. And he knew how to like, I think I say there's a lot. It comes down to like being a bit of an|||暧昧关系，就应该直接进监狱。当时我就觉得：兄弟，这特么是从哪儿冒出来的？我都三年没跟你说过话了。你居然还在想着我。我现在和这么棒的一个人在一起。你知道我和这个人在一起。但他还是给我发了信息，我的胃里顿时有了那种感觉。它好像翻江倒海了一下，我当时就想：天哪。我又重新感受到了所有的这些情绪。我记得就在三个月前，我还在想：我为什么曾经……有一段时间我一直在想：我当初怎么会陷入那种境地？而我的答案是：因为他知道如何让我感到非常焦虑。他知道如何——我想我经常这么说。这归结于我有点像个
overachiever and a bit of a perfectionist. Like everything else in my life, much like your friend, right, I had to work hard for. And there was this whole sense that like, what's easy, like, if it was easy, everyone could have it. So the relationship that was most hard to obtain, the person's attention that was most hard to obtain was the one that I should focus on. And I think that made me incredibly anxious and he really knew how to leverage that. And it was just this wild feeling of being like, wow, I'm like straight back in this time for just that second. I feel exactly how that felt. And it gave me like a sense of forgiveness of like, yeah, no wonder. No wonder. Like I was getting so wrapped up in this when you're in those situations, like everything is just
overachiever and a bit of a perfectionist. Like everything else in my life, much like your friend, right, I had to work hard for. And there was this whole sense that like, what's easy, like, if it was easy, everyone could have it. So the relationship that was most hard to obtain, the person's attention that was most hard to obtain was the one that I should focus on. And I think that made me incredibly anxious and he really knew how to leverage that. And it was just this wild feeling of being like, wow, I'm like straight back in this time for just that second. I feel exactly how that felt. And it gave me like a sense of forgiveness of like, yeah, no wonder. No wonder. Like I was getting so wrapped up in this when you're in those situations, like everything is just|||过于追求卓越的人，还有点完美主义。就像我生活中的其他所有事情一样，很像你的朋友，对吧？我必须通过努力才能得到。并且有一种普遍的感觉，那就是：简单得来的东西……如果很容易得到，那每个人都能拥有了。所以，最难得到的亲密关系，最难得到的那个人的关注，才是我应该专注于去争取的。我想这让我变得极其焦虑，而他非常懂得如何利用这一点。那种感觉太疯狂了，就好像：哇，仅仅在那一秒钟，我又直接回到了那个时期。我完完全全感受到了当年的那种滋味。这让我产生了一种释怀的感觉，比如：是的，难怪。难怪。当我身处那些情境中时，我竟然陷得那么深，在那种情况下，一切都只是
playing on this like instinctual anxious drive, this sense of like I need to find stability here and the only way I can find stability is to like reach the conclusion of this relationship and make it into something more. I just think that like I don't know if that's been your experience, but that was the real reason I found myself in situationships for a very long time as well. A hundred percent. I can relate to everything you just said. In our book we actually have a quiz of like what type of dater you are. I'm curious if you took it, but I was an achiever dreamer and that combination was kind of a baby guessing that is what you are. Yeah. It actually was next to that. Okay. That's the exact notion that I had too of like,
playing on this like instinctual anxious drive, this sense of like I need to find stability here and the only way I can find stability is to like reach the conclusion of this relationship and make it into something more. I just think that like I don't know if that's been your experience, but that was the real reason I found myself in situationships for a very long time as well. A hundred percent. I can relate to everything you just said. In our book we actually have a quiz of like what type of dater you are. I'm curious if you took it, but I was an achiever dreamer and that combination was kind of a baby guessing that is what you are. Yeah. It actually was next to that. Okay. That's the exact notion that I had too of like,|||在操纵这种本能的焦虑驱动力，这种“我需要在里找到稳定性，而我找到稳定性的唯一方法就是让这段关系得出结论，把它变成更多”的感觉。我只是觉得——我不知道这是否也是你们的经历，但这确实是我长时间以来发现自己陷入暧昧关系的真正原因。百分之百。你刚才说的一切我都感同身受。在我们的书中，其实有一个关于“你是哪种类型约会者”的小测试。我很想知道你做过没有，我测试的结果是“成就梦想家”型，这个组合有点像——我盲猜你也是这种类型。是的。其实结果就在它旁边。好的。这也是我曾有过的确切想法，比如：
you know, I imagine this fantasy with this person and like for, you know, everyone can take the quiz even if you don't have the book and go to our website and take the quiz. But like, it's so fascinating because it's all about like, what are your strengths that you bring to dating, but then also what holds you back? And I think in that situation, it was like this getting ahead of yourself, making something romanticizing it. And this is also natural. That's why, like, with all of this that we talk about, it's like, these are just traps that everyone's falling for because it's instinctual to how dating and modern dating work. And this need to like win comes from this achiever's mindset of like, I still want to like get this person. 100%. And like you said, what is winning? I'm the winning is being with someone who doesn't even want to be with me. Like that doesn't seem like a great prize. I'm sorry. Like that seems pretty crap. How do you think, how do you think we can stop ourselves from really getting carried away in the early days? Because sometimes I find sometimes, you know, I've now been with my partner for a while. So. Not recently, but when I was dating and what a lot of people do ask me is, I meet this person and suddenly I'm fantasizing about the wedding that we're going to have in three years.
you know, I imagine this fantasy with this person and like for, you know, everyone can take the quiz even if you don't have the book and go to our website and take the quiz. But like, it's so fascinating because it's all about like, what are your strengths that you bring to dating, but then also what holds you back? And I think in that situation, it was like this getting ahead of yourself, making something romanticizing it. And this is also natural. That's why, like, with all of this that we talk about, it's like, these are just traps that everyone's falling for because it's instinctual to how dating and modern dating work. And this need to like win comes from this achiever's mindset of like, I still want to like get this person. 100%. And like you said, what is winning? I'm the winning is being with someone who doesn't even want to be with me. Like that doesn't seem like a great prize. I'm sorry. Like that seems pretty crap. How do you think, how do you think we can stop ourselves from really getting carried away in the early days? Because sometimes I find sometimes, you know, I've now been with my partner for a while. So. Not recently, but when I was dating and what a lot of people do ask me is, I meet this person and suddenly I'm fantasizing about the wedding that we're going to have in three years.|||你知道的，我对这个人怀有这种幻想，而且——即使你没有这本书，每个人也可以去我们的网站参加这个测试。但这个测试太迷人了，因为它完全关乎：你带入约会的优势是什么，同时又是什么在拖你的后腿？我想在这种情况下，就像是过于超前、把某事浪漫化了一样。这也是很自然的。这就是为什么我们谈论的所有这些，都只是每个人都会掉进去的陷阱，因为这是约会和现代约会运作方式的本能反应。这种想要“赢”的需求源于这种“成就者”的心态，即：“我仍然想搞定这个人。”百分之百。正如你所说，什么才叫赢？所谓的赢，是和一个甚至都不想和我在一起的人在一起。这听起来根本算不上什么好奖品。抱歉。这听起来太逊了。你觉得，你觉得我们该如何阻止自己在刚开始的时候就过于上头呢？因为有时候我发现——我已经和伴侣在一起一段时间了。所以……不是最近，但当我还在约会时，很多人都会问我：“我遇到了这个人，突然之间我就开始幻想我们三年后要举行的婚礼了。”
We've been on one day. Is that like just infatuation or is that a sign of like something deeper? How do you stop that from getting in the way of actually getting to know each other? Yeah, it's just such a great question because so many of us fall into that. And I would argue that it's very healthy to fantasize about a future with someone. If you don't do that, then maybe you don't have a heart, right? Like, it's good to feel like the warm and fuzzies about someone and be like, oh my gosh, maybe we could have a family together. But this sounds like typical dreamer where you get so ahead of yourself that you get wrapped and wrapped up in the story and then you forget about the reality of what's happening. So, you know, even in the book, we always tell everybody to just like fact check, write down all the things that are real, all the things you are feeling, and then just know that you can observe all of this, and all of this can exist at once. Don't feel bad for feeling this way, but also it's good to
We've been on one day. Is that like just infatuation or is that a sign of like something deeper? How do you stop that from getting in the way of actually getting to know each other? Yeah, it's just such a great question because so many of us fall into that. And I would argue that it's very healthy to fantasize about a future with someone. If you don't do that, then maybe you don't heart, right? Like, it's good to feel like the warm and fuzzies about someone and be like, oh my gosh, maybe we could have a family together. But this sounds like typical dreamer where you get so ahead of yourself that you get wrapped and wrapped up in the story and then you forget about the reality of what's happening. So, you know, even in the book, we always tell everybody to just like fact check, write down all the things that are real, all the things you are feeling, and then just know that you can observe all of this, and all of this can exist at once. Don't feel bad for feeling this way, but also it's good to|||我们才约会了一天。这只是迷恋，还是某种更深层情感的迹象？你如何阻止这种幻想阻碍你们真正去了解彼此呢？是的，这是一个非常好的问题，因为我们中有太多人都会陷入这种境地。我认为，幻想与某人的未来是非常健康的。如果你不那样做，那也许说明你没有心，对吧？比如，对某人产生那种温馨而美好的感觉是很好的，会觉得：“天哪，也许我们可以一起组建一个家庭。”但这听觉起来像是典型的梦想家，你会过于超前，以至于深陷于这个故事中无法自拔，然后却忘记了正在发生的现实。所以，你知道的，即使在书中，我们也总是告诉每个人要进行“事实核查”，写下所有真实的事情、你所有的真实感受，然后要知道你可以观察这一切，所有这些可以同时存在。不要因为有这种感觉而感到内疚，但同时，最好能
do a reality check every once in a while. Okay, it's only been three dates. Okay, I don't even know their middle name. Like, okay, like, we haven't had a conversation for longer than two, hours, like, it's good to just bring you back to reality, but it's okay if you fantasize every once in a while. Like, it's natural to do that. And in today's date and culture, too, we call it the expectation of love on demand, another trap that gets in our way. Because in today's world, everything happens at lightning speed, right? Like, you can get an Uber and you can order a meal and all the things, like at the touch of your fingertips. And of course, you expect that in dating too. So with this, like as soon as we meet someone that we like, we often get ahead of ourselves
do a reality check every once in a while. Okay, it's only been three dates. Okay, I don't even know their middle name. Like, okay, like, we haven't had a conversation for longer than two, hours, like, it's good to just bring you back to reality, but it's okay if you fantasize every once in a while. Like, it's natural to do that. And in today's date and culture, too, we call it the expectation of love on demand, another trap that gets in our way. Because in today's world, everything happens at lightning speed, right? Like, you can get an Uber and you can order a meal and all the things, like at the touch of your fingertips. And of course, you expect that in dating too. So with this, like as soon as we meet someone that we like, we often get ahead of ourselves|||偶尔进行一次现实检查。好吧，我们才约会了三次。好吧，我甚至不知道他们的中间名是什么。好吧，我们甚至没有进行过超过两小时的对话。适时把自己拉回现实是很好的，但偶尔幻想一下也没关系。这样做是很自然的。在当今的约会文化中，我们称之为“按需之爱的期望”，这是又一个挡在我们面前的陷阱。因为在当今世界，一切都以闪电般的速度发生，对吧？比如，你可以叫网约车、点外卖，所有这些都触手可及。当然，你在约会中也会期待这一点。所以伴随着这一点，一旦我们遇到喜欢的人，我们往往就会过于超前
and we start imagining this future and also couple in that people are really frustrated by dating and just want to get out. So it's all this like perfect storm of, you know, maybe not giving other people that could be potentially better partners for the long haul enough time and then focusing on people that we don't really know. Like you said, I really had to get realistic because this was a huge problem of mine. I remember even like when I met my partner now though, like I remember my best friend being like, so do you think you'll go out with him again? I'm like, you know, if I do, that would be awesome. And if I don't, that's also okay. Because I have no idea what's going on in his life after going out with him one time. And I think it really took
and we start imagining this future and also couple in that people are really frustrated by dating and just want to get out. So it's all this like perfect storm of, you know, maybe not giving other people that could be potentially better partners for the long haul enough time and then focusing on people that we don't really know. Like you said, I really had to get realistic because this was a huge problem of mine. I remember even like when I met my partner now though, like I remember my best friend being like, so do you think you'll go out with him again? I'm like, you know, if I do, that would be awesome. And if I don't, that's also okay. Because I have no idea what's going on in his life after going out with him one time. And I think it really took|||并且开始想象这个未来，再加上人们对约会感到非常沮丧并只想摆脱它。所以这就像是一场完美的风暴，你知道的，也许没有给那些可能更适合长期发展的潜在伴侣足够的时间，反而把注意力集中在我们并不真正了解的人身上。正如你所说，我真的必须变得现实一点，因为这是我的一个大问题。我还记得，即使当我遇到现在的伴侣时，我记得我最好的朋友曾问我：“那你觉得你还会跟他出去吗？”我说：“你知道的，如果我去，那太棒了。如果我不去，也没关系。”因为和他出去过一次之后，我根本不知道他的生活中发生了什么。我想这确实需要
conscious unlearning of those patterns. I guess the other thing that really factors into this and listening to you to you both talk about it, is this idea that, like, you should have this passionate all-consuming spark. You're everybody's love stories, and there's this huge idea of, like, you should know within the first, like, five minutes. Like, real love won't hide.
conscious unlearning of those patterns. I guess the other thing that really factors into this and listening to you to you both talk about it, is this idea that, like, you should have this passionate all-consuming spark. You're everybody's love stories, and there's this huge idea of, like, you should know within the first, like, five minutes. Like, real love won't hide.|||有意识地抛弃那些固有模式。我想另一件真正起作用的事情是——听你们俩谈论这些——就是那种观点，即你应该拥有那种充满激情、让人全身心投入的火花。在所有人的爱情故事中，都有这样一个根深蒂固的观念：你应该在前五分钟内就知道。就像真正的爱情是藏不住的一样。
And if you have to, like, take time and be patient with it, like, obviously it's not the one for you. It is also, it comes down to, like, if you wanted to, if she wanted to, they would. Oh, God, yeah. Which I am like, hmm. yeah, okay, like I get, I do get it. I think it's like a nice philosophy. But sometimes, like you said, there's other things happening in their life. Maybe they do really want to, but they can't. But also,
And if you have to, like, take time and be patient with it, like, obviously it's not the one for you. It is also, it comes down to, like, if you wanted to, if she wanted to, they would. Oh, god, yeah. Which I am like, hmm. yeah, okay, like I get, I do get it. I think it's like a nice philosophy. But sometimes, like you said, there's other things happening in their life. Maybe they do really want to, but they can't. But also,|||如果你必须花时间去经营、对它保持耐心，那很显然他不是你的真命天子/女。这也归结于那句话：“如果他想的话，如果她想的话，他们就会去做。”哦，天哪，是的。对此我的反应是：嗯。好吧，我懂，我确实懂。我觉得这算是一种美好的哲学。但有时，正如你所说，他们的生活中还发生着其他事情。也许他们确实很想，但心有余而力不足。而且，
it gives this expectation of, like, grand gestures and huge commitment very, very quickly, sometimes, like, the best love comes from slowing down and comes from taking your time. How do we do that? That's like the million-dollar question. How do you like slow down, actually enjoy dating, actually enjoy the process and getting to know someone in this like love on demand environment, in this like very urgent society that we live in? Oh, it's such a beautiful observation. I will tell you, I spent my 20s being addicted to love and my 30s chasing that high. And now being in my 40s, I realized that was all a ruse. Like that was not that that's not, that's not, what relationships are about. So I think it's, it's good to know that, you know, oh, I really
it gives this expectation of, like, grand gestures and huge commitment very, very quickly, sometimes, like, the best love comes from slowing down and comes from taking your time. How do we do that? That's like the million-dollar question. How do you like slow down, actually enjoy dating, actually enjoy the process and getting to know someone in this like love on demand environment, in this like very urgent society that we live in? Oh, such a beautiful observation. I will tell you, I spent my 20s being addicted to love and my 30s chasing that high. And now being in my 40s, I realized that was all a ruse. Like that was not that that's not, that's not, what relationships are about. So I think it's, it's good to know that, you know, oh, I really|||这会让人对宏大的表白和巨大的承诺产生一种非常非常迅速的期待，有时候，最美好的爱反而来自于慢下来，来自于不急不躁。我们该怎么做到这一点？这简直是价值百万的问题。在这个“按需之爱”的环境中，在我们生活的这个非常紧凑的社会里，你如何能够慢下来，真正享受约会，真正享受去了解一个人的过程？哦，多棒的观察啊。我告诉你，我20多岁时沉迷于爱情，30多岁时则在追逐那种多巴胺飙升的快感。现在到了40多岁，我才意识到那全都是骗局。那根本不是、那不是、那绝对不是亲密关系的真谛。所以我觉得，知道这一点很好，比如：“哦，我真的很
chase the butterflies or I'm chasing that grand, passionate feeling because as long as you are observing that, you know that's happening to you. But the second step to that is to say, am I feeling this passion for this person because they haven't called me back in two days? And I've now written this novel about them and I'm now addicted to the story of this person or are they actually showing signs of being a good partner? That's why I'm feeling love and passion for them. And in my 20s, I will tell you, I was chasing after people who were the first, how I described in the first way is they were not available, but I was so connected to the story of who they were that I began chasing not them with these fantasy characters.
chase the butterflies or I'm chasing that grand, passionate feeling because as long as you are observing that, you know that's happening to you. But the second step to that is to say, am I feeling this passion for this person because they haven't called me back in two days? And I've now written this novel about them and I'm now addicted to the story of this person or are they actually showing signs of being a good partner? That's why I'm feeling love and passion for them. And in my 20s, I will tell you, I was chasing after people who were the first, how I described in the first way is they were not available, but I was so connected to the story of who they were that I began chasing not them with these fantasy characters.|||在追逐小鹿乱撞的感觉，或者我在追逐那种宏大、激昂的情感”，因为只要你能察觉到这一点，你就知道这种事正在你身上发生。但这其中的第二步是去想：我对这个人产生这种激情，是因为他们两天没给我回电话吗？而我现在已经为他们脑补了一整部小说，并且沉迷于关于这个人的故事中？还是因为他们确实展现出了成为一个好伴侣的特质，所以我才对他们产生了爱意与激情？在我的20多岁时，我告诉你，我一直在追逐那些第一类人——就像我最初描述的那样，他们并不可得，但我与他们是谁的故事深深绑定在了一起，以至于我追逐的不是他们本人，而是这些幻想中的角色。
So now I can look back on that and say, okay, I'm glad I went through that experience. But I think this is the biggest shift for me in how I turn that around. My friend Amy told me this because I asked her like, why do you want to get married? Why do you want to have kids? Why do you want any of this stuff in life? And she said, it's not the achievements or the milestones.
So now I can look back on that and say, okay, I'm glad I went through that experience. But I think this is the biggest shift for me in how I turn that around. My friend Amy told me this because I asked her like, why do you want to get married? Why do you want to have kids? Why do you want any of this stuff in life? And she said, it's not the achievements or the milestones.|||所以现在我回过头来看，会觉得：好吧，我很高兴自己经历过那种体验。但我认为这是我实现转变的超级大转折点。我的朋友艾米曾对我说过这样一番话——因为我曾问她：“你为什么想结婚？你为什么想生孩子？你为什么要在生活中追求所有这些东西？”她回答说：重要的不是成就或里程碑。
It's I want to learn how I can expand my heart to the fullest. And I thought that was such a beautiful way of putting relationships and dating is it's not about the end result or getting someone or chasing this milestone. It's what can you do to love the fullest at each opportunity? And even if that person doesn't stay forever, you are using that opportunity to expand your heart. And I really hope that everybody can take that expansion in mind when they're dating because it makes us so much more of a beautiful, enjoyable and like self-focused experience. Absolutely. It's also this sense of like, what are you rushing towards? You know, what's the rush? And I know people are always like, well, I just want to do all these things with them. And I'm like, if you're going to be with them forever, they will happen. And you don't want to squeeze a whole relationship into like four years and then be like, wait, we actually never really like got to know each other. I always say it's like you've got to enjoy the waiting rooms, right? There are periods in your life. when you're in a waiting room. And it's kind of like, oh, like, you know, I'm not, I'm not like coming to the destination.
It's I want to learn how I can expand my heart to the fullest. And I thought that was such a beautiful way of putting relationships and dating is it's not about the end result or getting someone or chasing this milestone. It's what can you do to love the fullest at each opportunity? And even if that person doesn't stay forever, you are using that opportunity to expand your heart. And I really hope that everybody can take that expansion in mind when they're dating because it makes us so much more of a beautiful, enjoyable and like self-focused experience. Absolutely. It's also this sense of like, what are you rushing towards? You know, what's the rush? And I know people are always like, well, I just want to do all these things with them. And I'm like, if you're going to be with them forever, they will happen. And you don't want to squeeze a whole relationship into like four years and then be like, wait, we actually never really like got to know each other. I always say it's like you've got to enjoy the waiting rooms, right? There are periods in your life. when you're in a waiting room. And it's kind of like, oh, like, you know, I'm not, I'm not like coming to the destination.|||而是我想学会如何让我的心极尽所能地去扩张。我觉得她对亲密关系和约会的这种诠释太美妙了：它无关最终的结果、无关得到某人、也无关追逐某个里程碑。关键在于在每一个机会中，你能做些什么去尽情地去爱？即使那个人无法永远陪伴你，你也是在利用那个机会来拓展你的心胸。我真的希望每个人在约会时都能把这种“心胸的拓展”记在心里，因为这会让我们的约会体验变得更加美丽、愉快且专注于自我。完全正确。这也是一种感觉，比如：你到底在急什么？你知道的，有什么好急的？我知道人们总会说：“嗯，我只是想和他们一起做所有这些事情。”而我的看法是：如果你打算和他们永远在一起，这些事情自然会发生。你可不想把一段完整的关系压缩在四年之内，然后说：“等等，我们其实从来没有真正了解过彼此。”我总是说，这就好比你必须享受“候诊室”时光，对吧？在你的人生中，总有一些时期你正处于候诊室里。这就有点像是，哦，你知道的，我还没到达目的地。
I'm not at my destination. I'm just kind of in the middle. And I do think that relationships have those rooms as well where it's like, okay, this is the time when we can like sit and slow down and have a chat and like pick up a magazine and like just really, you know, fill out some forms, really get to know each other. Like I really value that in my own relationship is, you know, early days. Like it's only been two years as it is. it really does mean that there is a trust built there. And I know that the bedrock of my relationship
I'm not at my destination. I'm just kind of in the middle. And I do think that relationships have those rooms as well where it's like, okay, this is the time when we can like sit and slow down and have a chat and like pick up a magazine and like just really, you know, fill out some forms, really get to know each other. Like I really value that in my own relationship is, you know, early days. Like it's only been two years as it is. it really does mean that there is a trust built there. And I know that the bedrock of my relationship|||我还没到终点。我只是处在中间阶段。我确实认为亲密关系中也有这样的房间，比如：好吧，现在是我们坐下来、慢下来、聊聊天的时候，就像拿起一本杂志，或者真的去填一些表、真正了解彼此的时候。我非常珍惜我自己的亲密关系中的这一点，你知道的，在早期。虽然现在才在一起两年。但这确实意味着彼此之间已经建立了信任。我知道我的亲密关系的基石
is not excitement. There is excitement in there, but the bedrock is like true liking and knowledge. And like you said, like my heart has room to expand. It's like when you blow up a balloon slowly rather than just like giving one big push and like it explodes everywhere. So I like that advice a lot. I think this is easier, sad than down, but we need to. to like remember the long game here. Like I don't, we've had these conversations with people that, you know, got married super early and are now divorced. And they were saying how they felt like they lacked the communication skills, the relational skills. They just didn't do it because, you know, they just, everything just fell into place and it worked out. And of course,
is not excitement. There is excitement in there, but the bedrock is like true liking and knowledge. And like you said, like my heart has room to expand. It's like when you blow up a balloon slowly rather than just like giving one big push and like it explodes everywhere. So I like that advice a lot. I think this is easier, sad than down, but we need to. to like remember the long game here. Like I don't, we've had these conversations with people that, you know, got married super early and are now divorced. And they were saying how they felt like they lacked the communication skills, the relational skills. They just didn't do it because, you know, they just, everything just fell into place and it worked out. And of course,|||不是兴奋感。里面当然有兴奋感，但基石是真正的喜欢和相互了解。正如你所说，我的心有空间去扩张。这就像你慢慢地吹起一个气球，而不是猛地吹一口气然后让它到处炸开一样。所以我非常喜欢这个建议。我想这说起来容易做起来难，但我们需要。记住我们要看长远。就像我没有——我们曾与那些结婚非常早、现在已经离婚的人交谈过。他们说他们觉得自己缺乏沟通技巧和经营关系的技巧。他们之所以没学，是因为，你知道的，一切都顺理成章、水到渠成。当然了，
I was like, I'm not saying that every couple that gets married early, this is going to happen to. But I think if you are in the situation where you're like, I've been dating for a while, it's hard. Remember that it's all going to something. Like, you're learning at every step of the way here. And I really think that, like, dating is the perfect opportunity to, like, test out and train yourself and practice saying what you need. And we're always so afraid to in dating because we're like, we don't know this person well enough. I don't want to scare them away. But if we turn it like, why not scare away the wrong people? Like, that's filtering people out for you. Yeah. And then also like, I mean, I know for me a huge pivotal point was when I was like, okay, I'm going to date with my own needs at the forefront. So that involved getting clear about what those deeds even were, what I wanted. Because in the past, I was like the hitchhiker along for everyone else's ride. And that's why I was in all the situation ships. But then when you are able to turn. And
我当时就想，我并不是说每个很早就结婚的情侣都会这样。但我觉得，如果你处于那种情况，比如你觉得，我已经约会好一段时间了，这真的很难。你要记住，这一切都有意义。比如，你在这里每一步都在学习。我真的觉得，约会是一个绝佳的机会，可以让你去测试、训练自己，并练习说出你的需求。我们在约会时总是那么害怕这样做，因为我们会觉得，我们对这个人还不够了解。我不想把他们吓跑。但如果我们换个角度想，为什么不把不对的人吓跑呢？这就等于是在帮你筛选人群。对。然后还有就是，我知道对我来说，一个巨大的转折点是当我想：好吧，我要把自己的需求放在约会的最首要位置。所以这包括弄清楚这些需求到底是什么，我想要什么。因为过去，我就像个搭便车的人，顺便搭着别人的便车。这就是为什么我总是陷入各种暧昧不清的关系中。但当你能够转过头来——
turn it on yourself, then you're in control and you're making those decisions. And you can also look at it like, this person isn't the right one for me, not just, I need to be saved and get done with this. Oh, my goodness. Words I had wished, I heard a long time ago. Three or four years ago, those would have been incredibly helpful, but I had to learn it the hard way. We're going to take a short break. But when we return, we're going to talk more about how to date seriously and how to know if someone is the right one. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%.
把注意力转向自己时，你就掌握了主动权，你就在做那些决定。你也可以这样看待它：这个人并不适合我，而不仅仅是我需要被拯救并赶紧结束这一切。哦，天哪。这些话我真希望很久以前就能听到。三四年前，这些话绝对会对我帮助极大，但我只能通过吃力头来吸取教训。我们要进行短暂的休息。但当我们回来时，我们将更多地讨论如何认真地去约会，以及如何知道某人是否是那个对的人。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
我将剖析心理坚韧度、体能以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾以为种子油天生就会引发炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English.
这就是在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“T-W-O-Percent”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 颁奖典礼上拍打莉儿·金（Lil' Kim）胸部的那一幕吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉儿·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of America. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。其中包括最近的一集，我们邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill），大谈 80 年代的快克（crack）可卡因。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为美国的快克。我随时准备聊聊关于快克的话题，只要你们想听。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索了。我们今天还要聊聊艾滋病。
Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
欢迎来到我的新播客《The Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将结合我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的有特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时我们在追求某事时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
而我们却还在继续追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场场胜负的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人只是因为你害怕？因为这是两种截然不同的动机，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app,
绝对是这样。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地、纯粹地去做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《The Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App，
Search learning a hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
搜索“The Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这就引发了一场长达数年的诉讼战，旨在证明真相。你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试报告，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格（Greg）、莱斯利（The Lesbian）、迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice is. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I've got a more serious question.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。我有一个更严肃的问题。
I feel like the first half of this episode we talked about getting to know someone, doing some of the work in yourself around what kind of data you are, how you can go about going slow. Say you are with someone that's getting serious. You are having fun. You're vibing. Neither of you are seeing other people. It's exclusive.
我觉得这一集的前半部分我们讨论了如何了解一个人，在自己身上做了一些功课，比如你是什么类型的约会者，你该如何放慢节奏。假设你和某人在一起，关系正在变得认真。你们玩得很开心。你们很有默契。你们俩都没有和其他人约会。这是排他性的。
What if you have doubts? What if you still have questions lingering in the back of your mind, like three, four, five months in? Is that something that you should call it quits over? Or is it worth kind of giving them the grace and gift of time to see if it works? Yeah. And this goes back to our expectation of love on demand too. People feel like they need to know right away and also have no doubts in early dating. And it's so you're always going to have. have doubts. That's the reality of relationships, too. Relationships evolve and you're going to have moments where you're like, am I with the right person? So in our book, we actually make it very clear. We have a perfect partner equation. So you can just follow that formula. And really, it's a plug and chug, but also it grounds you into what matters in choosing a partner. And like, we really bully down to like there are only seven things that matter. And like one of them is consistency. Like is this person consistently showing up for you? But here's the thing though. Like with we can do all the overthinking because their thinker is one of their dating archetypes as
如果你有疑虑怎么办？如果你在三、四、五个月后，脑海深处依然存有疑问怎么办？这是你应该以此为由分手的理由吗？还是说，值得给对方一点时间和包容，看看是否能行得通？是的。这也追溯到我们对“即时恋爱”的期待。人们觉得他们需要立刻知道答案，而且在早期约会中不能有任何疑虑。而事实是，你总是会有疑虑的。这也是亲密关系的现实。关系是会演变的，总会有那么几个瞬间，你会觉得：我和对的人在一起吗？所以，在我们的书中，我们实际上把这一点写得很清楚。我们有一个“完美伴侣方程式”。所以你只需要遵循这个公式。说白了，它就像是一个套用公式，但它也能让你脚踏实地，明确在选择伴侣时什么才是最重要的。而且，我们真的把它精简到只有七个重要的方面。其中之一就是持续性。这个人是否一直在持续地为你付出？但问题是，我们可以过度思考，因为“思考者”也是他们的约会原型之一。
well. This person's going to be like every moment, is this the right person? This is the right person. At some point, you just got to say this is the right person until they're not the right person. We see this with so many relationships that span years and years. They're right until they're not. And that's okay. They do not need to be the right person forever. They are right for you based on your core needs, your values, et cetera. And that's all you really need to hold on to.
这个人会一直纠结：每一刻，这都是对的人吗？这真的是对的人吗？在某个时刻，你只能说：这就是对的人，直到他们不再是对的人为止。我们在许多持续了多年又多年的关系中看到了这一点。他们在对的时候是合适的，直到变得不合适为止。这没关系。他们不需要永远都是对的人。根据你的核心需求、价值观等，他们在当下对你而言是对的。这就是你真正需要坚持的。
You don't have to think like a hundred years down the line. I think it's understanding why you're having the hesitation too. Like UA was saying, is it something that's core to your values? or the way you feel or your futures aren't aligned. I just gave away some of the perfect partner equation. Or is it that stuff from your past is coming up that's causing you to feel that anxiety? Because I think there's a big difference if you're with the wrong person because you're fundamentally not aligned versus the normal anxieties that happen in relationships. And like, I know for me, I thought, like, once I met that person, it'd be all easy because the anxiety and the difficult part was in the dating.
你不必去考虑一百年后的事情。我觉得这也是为了去理解你为什么会有犹豫。就像乌娅（UA）刚才说的，这是否触及了你的核心价值观？还是你们的感受或对未来的规划不一致？我刚刚不小心剧透了一点“完美伴侣方程式”。还是说，你过去的经历被触发了，从而导致你感到这种焦虑？因为我认为，如果你和一个在根本上不合拍的人在一起，这和关系中发生的一般性焦虑之间，有着巨大的区别。而且我知道对我来说，我曾以为，一旦我遇到了那个人，一切都会变得轻松，因为焦虑和困难的部分只存在于约会阶段。
Because I met someone, I'm like, oh, this is like the type of person I was looking for, you know, everything on the outside is healthy. But what I've learned is like even in the healthiest relationships, we get triggered. Stuff comes up from our past. And there's a big differentiator if this person is wrong for you or it's kind of. coming from the back. I love the way that you put that because I do think that there are so many amazing people out there for us. We will never choose just one if we constantly think that the grass is greener. And of course, there is an important distinction between, like you said, you know, you have this beautiful relationship equation. There is an important distinction between,
因为我遇到了某人，我想，哦，这就是我一直在寻找的那种人，你知道的，表面上的一切都很健康。但我学到的是，即使在最健康的关系中，我们也会被触发。我们过去的经历会被勾起。这个人到底是不是真的不适合你，还是说这种抗拒感其实源于你的过去，这两者之间有很大的区别。我很喜欢你的这种说法，因为我确实觉得外面有那么多优秀的人在等着我们。如果我们总觉得草坪另一边的草更绿，我们就永远不会只选择一个人。当然，正如你所说，有一个重要的区别，你知道的，你拥有这个美妙的关系方程式。有一个重要的区别，
you know, not feeling certain because of big questions and not feeling certain because you're like, oh, could I have something more exciting? You know, could I have the butterflies again? I honestly see this a lot with people in their 20s where they're like, oh my God, my relationship just feels so stable and we're so used to chasing the high of early love that, you know, I had a friend who was in this gorgeous, beautiful relationship. She left it for similar reasons. And they are now back together because she was like, I just realized that actually this person was
你知道的，不是因为存在重大问题而感到不确定，而是因为你觉得：哦，我是不是能找到更刺激的？你知道，我是不是能再次体验到那种心跳的感觉？我老实说，这在20多岁的人身上经常看到，他们会觉得：天哪，我的关系太稳定了，我们太习惯于追逐早期恋爱的刺激感了，以至于……我有个朋友曾拥有一段非常美妙的恋情。她因为类似的理由离开了。而他们现在又复合了，因为她觉得：我只是突然意识到，其实这个人真的很棒。
amazing. They were everything that I wanted. I was just looking for something that actually a past version of me wanted more, which was something exhilarating and intoxicating and addictive. Is that the relationship that's going to take me till my 30s, to my 40s to my 50s? Is that the relationship I want to raise children within? Probably not. Probably not. But there are sometimes those situations, and you guys have this amazing episode, which I'm just going to plug here because it's so good about whether you should leave a good, whether you should leave a good, not great relationship. And if that is the case, this relationship is like, it's fine, it's okay, it's no amazing. And you do decide to leave. How do you get over the fear of never finding
他们就是我想要的一切。我当时只是在寻找一种过去版本的自己更渴望的东西，也就是那种令人兴奋、让人迷醉、容易上瘾的东西。这段关系会陪伴我走到30岁、40岁、50岁吗？这是我想与之共同抚养孩子的关系吗？可能不会。可能不会。但有时确实会有这种情形，你们有一集非常棒的节目——我在这里顺便安利一下，因为它实在太好了——探讨了你是否应该离开一段“不错但并非极好”的关系。如果是这种情况，这段关系感觉还行，挺好，但谈不上惊艳。如果你真的决定离开，你该如何克服“再也找不到更好的人”的恐惧？
someone better? If this is in your stars, if this is in your path, this relationship isn't right. How do you stop yourself from staying for longer than you should? Yeah. So I was 42 years old when I found out my partner of five years had been cheating on me. We were making plans to start a family. We were in the middle of trying to conceive when I found all the text messages that nobody should ever read from their partner. So here's the thing. after this breakup and it was hard, it was devastating, I realized if I can get through this on my own,
如果这是命中注定的，如果这是你人生必经之路，这段关系就不对。你该如何阻止自己停留过久？是的。所以当我发现我交往五年的伴侣出轨时，我42岁。我们当时正在计划组建家庭。当我们正试图备孕时，我却发现了那些任何人都不应该从伴侣手机里读到的短信。所以情况是这样的，在这段分手经历之后——那段经历非常艰难，甚至可以说是毁灭性的——我意识到，如果我能靠自己挺过这一关，
then I am perfectly great. Like, if this is the default of my life is to be strong and independent and be like this warrior on my own, then anybody who comes in my life is just additive. So having that kind of reset going back into dating, it was so refreshing because I didn't feel like I needed to hold on to people. I knew that whoever was meant for me will be in my life and whoever was not meant for me will naturally filter themselves out. I did not need to force people to be in my life. I did not need to force people to be in relationships with me. And that allowed me to attract the right people because these were people like, oh, her life is great. I want to add to it. I want to be a better part of this life.
那么我完全可以过得很好。如果我生活的常态就是变得坚强、独立，像个独行女战士一样，那么任何走进我生活的人都只是锦上添花。所以有了这种心态的重置，当我重新开始约会时，感觉是如此清新，因为我不再觉得我需要死死抓住任何人。我知道，任何注定属于我的人都会留在我的生命里，而任何不属于我的人自然会被筛选出去。我不需要强求任何人留在我的生活中。我不需要强求任何人与我维持恋爱关系。这让我能够吸引到对的人，因为这些人会觉得：“哦，她的生活太棒了。我想为它锦上添花。我想成为这段美好生活的一部分。”
Like, great, come along. But I don't need a relationship. I don't need a partner. When we have the scarcity mindset, we feel like we need someone to save us. Like a relationship is going to bring us to this island where everybody's safe and fed and roofed. And that's like, that's not how it works, right? Like, it's just relationships won't save you if you can't save yourself.
那太好了，加入吧。但我不需要一段关系。我不需要一个伴侣。当我们拥有匮乏心态时，我们会觉得我们需要某人来拯救我们。就好像一段关系会把我们带到一个每个人都安全、有饭吃、有屋顶的世外桃源。但这根本不是那么回事，对吧？如果连你自己都救不了自己，任何关系也救不了你。
I think though it's natural what you were saying, like, especially like we tie in like a present bias, right? We look at what's in front of us currently as like having more weight than what could be in the future. And it's really hard to see that something better could be around the corner. Like looking at UA's situation, I feel like you're in a much better relationship now and place now. But in the thick of that breakup, you could not see that. You could not know that. So it's a really hard. situation that makes us often overstay things that aren't working. I think the hardest one, too, is like when it's a good relationship, like nothing's wrong, but you're just like, is there something more fulfilling for me? And of course, we recommend, you know, having all the conversations, doing the work, going to couples therapy, not just throwing in the towel at one feeling of that. But if you keep feeling that and you're like, fundamentally, I know this person isn't right for me, You also have to honor that too and honor that and trust that something will be out there that is better serve for you. Because if you're fundamentally feeling that way, then like you do deserve something more.
不过我觉得这是很自然的，就像你刚才说的，尤其是我们将“当下的偏见”联系在一起，对吧？我们认为眼前看到的东西比未来可能发生的事情更有分量。而且真的很难预见到转角处可能会有更好的东西。就像看乌娅的情况，我觉得你现在处于一段好得多的关系中，也处于更好的生活状态中。但在分手的至暗时刻，你是看不到这一点的。你无法预知这一点。所以这是一个非常棘手的状况，常常让我们在行不通的事情上过度停留。我觉得最难的情况也是，当这是一段不错的关系时——一切都没毛病，但你就是会想：对我来说是不是还有更充实的东西？当然，我们建议进行所有的沟通、做足功课、去看夫妻治疗，而不是仅仅因为产生了一种这种感觉就轻易放弃。但如果你一直有这种感觉，并且觉得：从根本上讲，我知道这个人不适合我。你也必须正视这一点，去尊重这种感受，并相信外面会有更适合你的人。因为如果你从根本上有这种感觉，那么你确实值得拥有更好的。
And so does the person you're with. I was going to say, yeah, so does the person. You're with like imagine if you were with a partner who was looking at being like, I just don't, like I'm not going to leave them because, you know, they're good, not great. Right. That would break my heart. part if my boyfriend or my partner was like, yeah, she's, she's okay, but I'm too scared to leave her. Yeah. And that's going to be the rest of my life. Like absolutely not. You almost owe it to that person to like take that. And to yourself. Like yes. You owe it to yourself as well because that's
你身边的这个人也是。我正想说，是的，你身边的人也是。想象一下，如果你和一个伴侣在一起，而对方心里在想：我只是不想……我不会离开他们，因为……他们人还不错，但也算不上极好。对吧？如果我的男友或伴侣觉得“嗯，她还行吧，但我太害怕而不敢离开她”，这会让我心碎的。是的，而且余生都要这样过吗？绝对不行。你几乎可以说是欠对方一个痛快，必须做出决定。也是对自己的一种负责。就像是，没错。这也是对自己的一种负责，因为那
still your reality. And I love what you said of like, okay, you might not find a better relationship, but you'll find yourself. And isn't that just as valuable? Because there are people who go through their entire lives who do not find that. And I say that with the most serious level of gravity, having seen it in family members of mine, actually, who I'm like, you know, you married, like the first person you met and now you're like 70, 80 and like I can just see that only now are you figuring yourself out as, you know, as someone who's older and it's beautiful that they're getting that opportunity. But it is something that you need to take seriously. You can't, like, there's never going to be a good time to end a relationship, ever.
依然是你的现实。我特别喜欢你刚才说的那句话：好吧，你可能找不到一段更好的关系，但你会找到你自己。难道这不也同样珍贵吗？因为确实有些人度过了整个人生，却从未找到真正的自我。我是怀着最严肃、最郑重的态度说出这句话的，因为我在我的一些家庭成员身上实际看到过这种情况。当时我在想：你知道吗，你和遇到的第一个人结了婚，现在你70岁、80岁了，我能看出直到现在，你才作为年长者真正开始弄懂自己是谁。他们能获得这个机会固然美好。但这是一件你需要认真对待的事情。你不能……结束一段关系永远没有所谓的“最佳时机”。
And there's never going to be, like, the final, you know, especially if you're with someone who's, like, really great and, like, kind and happy, like, if you're waiting for them to, like, screw up as an excuse to, like, break up with them. I honestly think that's a little bit manipulative as well, because you're going to push them into those situations where they're going to have to. Take, like, take the reins. Like, I love the, I think the overarching theme of everything you guys say is, like, being the driver's seat of your love life. And that also means having, like, if you're going to be in the driver's
而且也永远不会有完美的时刻，特别是当你和一个非常善良、体贴、快乐的人在一起时，如果你在等他们犯错来作为和你分手的借口。老实说，我觉得这也有点操纵的意味，因为你会把他们逼到那种不得不……主动采取行动的境地。我真的很喜欢——我觉得你们所说的一切，其核心主题就是成为你爱情生活中的驾驶员。这也意味着，如果你要坐在驾驶座上，
seat, you've also going to make some hard calls that might include, you know, leaving someone who is good, not great. But when you're saying actually inspired something that we talk, Julie and I talk about all the time, is sometimes we evaluate our relationships on the wrong things. Like, oh, this person's so nice and faithful and kind. Like, I should stay with them because they are a good person. Well, just being with someone because they're a good person doesn't actually do anything for anybody. You want to be with a partner who is committed to growing with you, who's committed to expanding
你也必须做出一些艰难的决定，其中可能包括离开一个“不错但并非极好”的人。但当你们提到这个时，实际上激发了我和朱莉经常讨论的一个话题：有时我们用错误的标准来评估我们的关系。比如，“这个人太好了、太忠诚、太善良了。我应该和他在一起，因为他是个好人。”然而，仅仅因为一个人是个好人就和他在一起，对任何人来说其实都没有实质性的帮助。你想和一个致力于与你共同成长、致力于和你一起拓宽
the relationship with you. The minute your partner shuts down or you shut down from that growth, that relationship is over because you can no longer evolve that relationship, no matter how kind or nice or great this person is. So instead of us being like, oh, I can't leave a person who's so nice and great, I would have just challenged people to say, have you set up your partner for success in terms of how we've had discussions about growing together? And where can we expand more into? Where can we be better at in our relationship? And see if your partner's receptive to that. Just like hang your hat on someone being a good person or nice,
关系边界的伴侣在一起。一旦你的伴侣停滞不前，或者你对这种成长选择关闭心扉，这段关系就结束了，因为无论这个人有多善良、多好、多棒，你们都无法再推动这段关系向前发展。因此，与其纠结于“我不能离开一个这么好、这么棒的人”，我更愿意向大家提出挑战：在共同成长的讨论上，你是否为你的伴侣创造了成功的条件？我们可以在哪些方面进一步拓展？在我们的关系中，我们可以在哪些方面做得更好？然后看看你的伙伴是否能接受这一点。仅仅把希望寄托在一个人是个好人或人很好上，
it's just not enough, simply not enough for a relationship. So this is an interesting tidbit, but like when we did that episode, there was a specific couple that had come to us that was in mind, and they actually stayed together and years later,
这是远远不够的，对一段关系来说简直远远不够。所以这是一个有趣的插曲，当我们制作那一集节目时，脑海中其实有一个特定的情侣案例。他们最终留在了彼此身边，多年后，
they are super happy and the doubts are gone, which is fascinating because your instinct is to be like, leave, go find someone else, but I think that actually goes back to like some of the challenges with modern dating, that's always the instinct. And that's why we're kind of in or headed towards what we're calling the love crisis,
他们过得非常幸福，当初的疑虑也烟消云散了。这非常迷人，因为你的第一直觉通常是“离开，去找别人”。但我认为这实际上可以追溯到现代约会的一些挑战，这种冲动总是存在。这就是为什么我们正身处或正走向我们所称的“爱情危机”，
where dating is so hard that people don't want to do it anymore or the mental health aspect is getting so out of control that you wonder, like, is it even worth it? And if we're always on to the decks, we can never develop the relationship. So I like that example because it's like what you were saying, UA, of like, when you look at what's missing, how are you looking at it? And can you have that, like, come to conversation of, like, how do we move that barrier? And then if you've done all the work and you're still not there, at least you know you did it instead of just moving on. I love that. And I like, I really like this realistic approach of, like, look at the right things.
在危机中，约会变得如此艰难，以至于人们甚至不想再尝试了，或者心理健康问题变得如此失控，以至于你禁不住会想：这真的值得吗？如果我们总是急于进入下一段关系，我们就永远无法真正发展一段深刻的关系。所以我很喜欢这个例子，因为就像你说的，乌娅，当你审视所缺失的东西时，你是如何看待它的？你是否能进行那种推心置腹的对话：“我们该如何打破这个壁垒？”然后，如果你已经做完了所有的功课，但仍然觉得不对劲，至少你知道自己尝试过，而不是仅仅一走了之。我太喜欢这个观点了。而且我真的很喜欢这种现实的态度，即：关注正确的事情。
and the order I've gotten that saying of like relationships or work, I used to be so scared of that saying. I used to be like, no, no, no, no, it should be easy. Yes, but like you go to the gym when you want to. Like you look after your body. That's hard work, but you still enjoy it. Everything is work. Everything is work. Exactly.
以及那种说“关系需要经营”的说法。我以前非常害怕这句话。我以前总是想：不不不，不，不，一切都应该轻而易举才对。是的，但就像你想去健身房时一样。你要照顾自己的身体。那是一项艰苦的工作，但你依然乐在其中。万物皆需经营。万物皆需经营。没错。
Anything that's good is work and is a choice. I actually think that like the easiest things in life aren't always what having. You know, it's easy. to like be passive in your life. It's easy to sit on the couch and it's easy to like eat the food that's like on your way home and it's easy to do X, Y, Z. Is that going to put you in the best place? Probably not. Same goes for a relationship at times. Especially like, I don't know, especially when there is just so much about them that you do really like and that is important. I know we're giving like conflicting advice here guys, but I think the basis of what we're saying is if you have
任何美好的事物都需要付出努力，也都是一种选择。其实我觉得生活中最简单的事情并不总是最值得拥有的。你知道的，在生活中保持被动很容易。坐在沙发上很容易，在回家路上顺便买点快餐吃很容易，做这样那样的事也很容易。这能带给你最好的生活状态吗？可能不会。恋爱关系有时也是如此。尤其是，当他们身上确实有那么多你真心喜欢且极其重要的特质时。我知道我们在这里给出了相互矛盾的建议，伙计们，但我们所说的基础是，如果你
have an instinct that maybe this relationship isn't right for you. Investigate it further. Is it for a reason that is something that you can work on? Or is it something fundamental about your character and your plans and your visions? The first step is definitely to really test that out with your partner and really do the work and the interrogation if they are someone who is genuinely a great person for you. And then it's kind of up to you. Like maybe the reason our advice is like this way and that way is because there is no one answer. But I love the analogy you gave of that couple. It's heartwarming. I think the question, too, is like, what's hard? Because, like, if you're, like, constantly
有种直觉，觉得这段关系可能不适合你。那就进一步去探究它。这是因为某个你可以去改进的原因？还是因为你的性格、规划和愿景存在根本上的冲突？第一步绝对是和你的伴侣好好去验证这一点，认真地去努力、去剖析，看看对方是否真的是一个非常适合你的人。然后就取决于你自己的决定了。也许我们给出的建议之所以有时这样、有时那样，是因为这个问题本就没有标准答案。但我很喜欢你给出的那对情侣的例子。那很暖心。我觉得问题也在于：什么才叫“难”？因为如果你
trying to get attention from a situation ship that is telling you outright that they don't want to commit to you, that's not the right relationship for you. But if it's hard because it's actually making you confront parts of yourself and, you know, feelings that are coming up or emotions that you've stuffed away, that's, like, the right type of hard. that's challenging you to be a better person. So again, I think it is conflicting, but we have to come back to like what the root is of like what is actually the hard. I love that.
一直在苦苦追求一个明确表示不想对你承诺的“暧昧对象”的关注，那这就不是一段适合你的关系。但如果感到难，是因为它实际上迫使你去面对自身的某些部分，去面对那些你一直压抑的感受或情绪，那这就是“正确的那种难”——它在挑战你，让你成为一个更好的人。所以再次说明，我觉得这听起来有些矛盾，但我们必须回归本质，弄清楚到底是什么在让你觉得困难。我太喜欢这个观点了。
Now, we have to wrap up because I've just got completely, I've gotten completely carried away. It's like, I just want to ask you every single dating question I've ever had. I think to finish the episode and I ask a lot of my guests this, what would each of you pick one thing, the best piece of advice, that you would give your 20-something-year-old self around dating? What do you wish that you had known back then that the listeners could know now? I think for me it's trust in your timing, especially in your 20s. There's so much pressure to, you know, meet these artificial milestones.
好了，我们必须收尾了，因为我刚才完全聊嗨了。那种感觉就像是，我只想把你所有关于约会的疑问都抛出来问个遍。我想在节目结束时问一个问题——这也是我经常问我的嘉宾的问题：你们每个人会选择哪一件事，作为给20多岁的自己在约会方面最好的建议？你希望自己当年就知道些什么，从而现在可以让听众们也了解到？我觉得对我来说，是要相信自己的节奏，尤其是在20多岁的时候。人们有太大的压力去达成这些人为设定的里程碑。
And it's so much better to take your time and be with the right person. And again, it goes back to the long game. And, you know, getting into this mindset, too, of I'm the one in control. I'm figuring this out. It's not the apps. It's not my city. It's not all other people. Like, I'm the one leading is so empowering too.
放慢脚步，和对的人在一起，要好得多。这又回到了长线思维上。并且，也要培养这样一种心态：我是掌控者。我在摸索着前进。问题不是出在约会上。不是因为我所在的城市。也不是因为其他人。由我来主导一切，这种感觉同样会赋予你强大的力量。
So if you could combine those two mindsets of, like, you know, things will work out for me, especially if I make this a priority with I'm in the driver's seat, then I think that really sets you up. for a lot more success. I think even asking the question you just asked is a really good way to think about dating. And the question is, if you're, let's say, in your 30s or 40s, what did you learn in your 20s about dating? Ask yourself that question in your 20s. You know, ask yourself, like, in this situation I'm in right now, 10 years down the line, what would I tell that person that I learned from it? I think in the 20s, you don't need it. You don't need it. You don't need it. You don't need to be like, I have to figure it all out and I have to get it all right because you'll never
所以，如果你能将这两种心态结合起来——“事情会好起来的，尤其是当我把它当作优先事项时”以及“我掌握着方向盘”，那么我认为这真的会为你带来巨大得多的成功。我觉得，甚至连去问你刚才提出的那个问题，都是思考约会的一种极佳方式。那个问题就是：假设你正处于30多岁或40多岁，你在20多岁时从约会中学到了什么？在20多岁的时候就问自己这个问题。你知道的，去问自己：在此时此刻我所处的这种境地中，十年后，我会对那个时期的自己说，我从中吸取到了什么教训？我觉得在20多岁时，你不需要一切都……你不需要做到完美。你不需要觉得“我必须把一切都搞清楚，我必须把每件事都做对”，因为你永远不可能
get it all right or figure it all out. But it's such a great place with so much freedom to play and to experiment and discover. Just know that you are intentional about the discovery process. You're not repeating the same patterns of behavior, that every moment is teaching you something so that when you do reach 30, you go, yep, in my 20s, I learned all of it. Like I have a whole list of things I learned. And also, like, your dating life and life doesn't end at 30. There is such a pressure to be like, make sure that you've like picked up a partner along the way. Oh my God, absolutely not.
把每件事都做对，也不可能把一切都搞清楚。但这是一个有着巨大自由去玩耍、去实验、去探索的绝佳人生阶段。只要确保你在探索的过程中是有意图的。你不是在重复相同的行为模式，而是让每一个时刻都在教导你一些东西，这样当你真正到了30岁时，你就会说：“是的，在20多岁时，我把这些都学透了。我有一长串学到的心得。”而且，你的约会生活和整个人生并不会在30岁时结束。社会上有很大的压力，好像在催促着你“确保你在人生路上顺便捡到一个伴侣”。天哪，绝对不是这样。
Oh, my God. No. You have so much time. You have so much time. So I want to thank you both for coming on to the show. I also really want to plug your book, How to Be Datable. By the time it comes out on January 28th, correct? Yeah.
天哪，才不是呢。你有大把的时间。你有的是时间。所以我要感谢你们两位来到节目中。我也真的很想安利你们的书——《如何成为一个值得约会的人》（How to Be Datable）。这本书将于1月28日正式发行，对吧？是的。
Yeah. And it's incredible. It's a really good book. And it's practical and it's helpful and it's modern. And there's just so many nuggets of wisdom in it. So I'll leave a link to pre-order the book in the description of this episode. Where can the listeners find your podcast? Where can they find you both? So many places. We're all over the internet. But really, wherever podcasts are, Apple, Spotify, and, yeah, datable podcast. podcast.com or how to be datable.com. Brilliant. Again, thank you so much for coming on and for your beautiful advice for us 20-somethings. I hope that you guys, the listeners, enjoyed this episode.
是的。这是一本非常棒的书。它既实用、有帮助又很现代。里面充满了各种智慧的结晶。所以我会把预购这本书的链接放在本集节目的简介里。听众们在哪里可以找到你们的播客？他们又在哪里可以找到你们两位？有很多地方。我们在整个互联网上都能找到。不过，主要还是在各大播客平台，比如 Apple、Spotify，以及 datablepodcast.com 或 howtobedatable.com。太棒了。再次非常感谢你们来到这里，并为我们这些20多岁的人分享了如此美妙的建议。希望收听节目的听众们会喜欢这一集。
Everything else that you need will be in the link or in the description of this episode. Make sure that you leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening. Give us a follow so you know when new episodes are coming up, especially with 12 months of guests happening at the moment. We have some more amazing guests on their way. And until next time, stay safe. Be kind and be gentle to yourself. We will talk soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
你需要的所有其他内容都可以在本集节目的链接或简介中找到。请务必在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify 或你正在收听的任何平台上留下五星好评。关注我们，以便了解新节目的更新，特别是目前我们邀请了为期一二个月的嘉宾阵容。我们还会有更多精彩的嘉宾做客。直到下次，祝大家保重。保持善良，对自己温柔一些。我们很快再聊。《2%》。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。我在我的播客《2%》中。我将剖析心理坚韧度、体能以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, or fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。这就是在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“TWO%”。在《Look Back At It》播客中。1979年，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild...
我是萨姆·杰（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家们一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是一个疯狂的……
I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with.
我的意思是，那是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《The Hard Way》。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本不安全去进行的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的执照专业人士一起探讨。有多少男人带着盔甲？这向世界发出了一个信号：你不是好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去使用它。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《The Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试报告，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app,
格雷格、莱斯利、迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。请在 iHeartRadio App、
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。